dude you are chunky hi my name is Hefty
I'm a five-year-old English Bulldog I
love going on picnics with my parent
anything outside that involves food I'm
all in for so I love that his name is
Hefty it tells me that the owner
definitely has a sense of humor I hope
that the owner can't hear me saying this
but I love
ugly dogs you're not ugly
very soft a lot of people talk about the
soft coat hi I'm meatball that's the
cutest name so far I come on strong
because I'm excited to see you but give
me a few minutes I'll be asleep on your
leg anyway wanna kiss oh I definitely
think I would vibe with meatballs owner
hi my name is Penny I'm a two-year-old
Cavalier King Charles Spaniel like my
owner I'm up for anything whether it's
an all-day hike or an afternoon lounging
on the couch is your owner as cute as
you are she's probably cuter than me